the movie begins on a large deserted
island in the middle of nowhere the
isolated area is surrounded by a vast
ocean that borders its sides with no
means of escape a young woman named zoa
wakes up stranded on the Island's Shores
with no recollection of what happened in
the last 12 hours frustrated she
explores the island searching for any
sign of human life a few minutes later
zoa finds an empty bottle lying on the
sand on picking it up she gets a
flashback to the events that led to her
isolation the scene suddenly shifts to
one week ago when it All Began back in
the city zoa returns home after a long
day of work and exchanges pleasantries
with her younger sister Gabby moments
later she settles into bed and is
stunned to receive a strange message
from an unknown number zoa is
immediately suspicious of the text but
goes against her instincts and decides
to reply to the mystery number upon
questioning the anonymous texter reveals
that they are the correspondent of a new
beverage company named Eden and informs
zoa that she has been selected to attend
the company's launch party the mystery
texter explains that the event is an
all-expenses paid trip to a remote
island and Promises to be a lot of fun
Zoe is fascinated by the offer and
quickly welcomes it as she grins at the
idea of attending a free Island party
her Nigerian prince will probably even
greet her when she arrives however
before accepting the offer the
correspondent tables a set of guidelines
that she must follow one do not reveal
the event's location to a second party
and two do not bring anyone along zoa
finds the rules quite sketchy but agrees
to them for fear of losing her
invitation the following weekend she
packs her bags and makes her way to the
pickup station despite agreeing to the
company's rules zoa brings her best
friend Judith along as the duo heads to
the secret location on arrival if they
meet a fellow invitee named Aldo and
together the trio gets led to an
abandoned building by an automated drone
eventually the mini aircraft leaves them
and the group is left facing a locked
door seconds later a masked man appears
and lets the trio inside the building
where they find and socialize with other
invitees fortunately they don't have to
wait long as an Envoy of party bosses
arrives to take them to the island the
guests swiftly race into the vehicles
and spend the night dancing as they
approach their destination several hours
later they finally arrive at a Seaport
as the masked organizers Usher them to a
boat however before the invitees can
enter the cruise they're made to pass
through a verification checkpoint Judith
flinches on seeing this as she doesn't
have an invite but approaches the
checkpoint nonetheless thankfully her
gamble pays off as she is allowed to
join the company despite lacking an
invite the guests are all thoroughly
searched and are even made to pass a
metal detector as a precautionary
measure in addition they are also
ordered to drop their phones as a
prerequisite for entering the boat the
partygoers instantly find this very
suspicious but eventually succumb to the
organizer's demands as they surrender
their cell phones to them after all the
arrangements have been made they all
board the boat and begin their trip to
the vacation island about an hour later
they finally arrive at their destination
and are are each given a wristband by
the ushers once settled they begin
partying and spend the night drinking
and dancing during the event zoa runs
into a guy named Daniel and the duo
instantly hits it off amidst the
festivities the head of organizer Astrid
makes a grand announcement she reveals
that 100 guests were invited to the
launch party however the beverage
company randomly selects only five of
The 100 attendees to try their new
energy drink the selected candidates
include Africa Ebon Charlie Aldo and zoa
the five guests are individually handed
the mystery drink and each one quickly
gulps it and returns to partying
meanwhile Judith searches the crowd for
zoa and eventually finds her way to a
tent on the Island's Shores there she
sees two of the organizers attacking and
drowning a man in a water barrel she is
instantly spooked by this and races off
to continue her search for zoa on the
other end of the island zoa having a
terrible reaction to the mystery drink
wanders in a circle as she hallucinates
she eventually makes her way to the top
of a high cliff and is seconds away from
falling when a strange man appears and
saves her zoa continues hallucinating
and shortly after passes out as she
spends the night asleep on the cliff
right then we return to the movie start
zoa wakes up alone and wanders the
island in search of any inhabitants
fortunately she finds the other four
hand-picked guests who tried the mystery
drink and together they explore the
island for Clues after hours of
searching they realize the rest of the
guests have left on the boat thus
leaving them alone on the island as they
try to figure out their next move a
drone appears which leads them to a
mansion on the opposite end of the
islands there they are shocked to
discover a village of Island inhabitants
governed by Astrid the head organizer
she welcomes the stranded group to the
modern civilization and explains that
they were unfortunately left behind by
the company's boat however she assures
them of the vessel's return and offers
them a place to live while they wait zoa
is relieved to hear this but is left
worrying about Judith meanwhile each of
the five guests deployed to a different
department where they share the space
with the other inhabitants zoa swiftly
makes her way to her allocated apartment
and meets her new roommates Claudia and
Nico who turns out to be the strange guy
that rescued her the night before zoa
thanks him for coming to her Aid and the
duo instantly hits things off while a
quiet Claudia merely stares at them from
a distance the following day the group
inquires about the boat's arrival much
to their dismay they are informed that
the boat can't land ashore as the tides
are too strong though disappointed most
of them believe this and enjoy their
stay on the island however a distrustful
Aldo grows suspicious of the Island's
activities and becomes weary of the
organizers in the following scene zoa
spots one of the Island's inhabitants
named Orson and finds him eerily
familiar upon pondering zoa realizes
that he was with Judith on the night of
her arrival concerned she closely
follows and questions him about Judith's
whereabouts however Orson denies meeting
Judith and it displays an aggressive
nature which makes zoa even more
concerned about her friend safety
moments later Orson walks away while zoa
runs to the central Mansion there she is
shocked to see all the Island's
inhabitants engaging in a therapy
exercise upon her arrival Astrid spots
and invites her to join the exercise a
skeptical zoa is hesitant about joining
the program but with some cajoling
eventually agrees to do it the head
organizer asks Zoe a series of questions
about her childhood her family and her
past trauma causing her to reveal some
of her deepest Secrets it turns out that
zoa had a rough childhood as her mom was
a heroin addict while her dad was absent
for most of her life hence she was
single-handedly tasked with caring for
her younger sister Gabby at the end of
the session zoa feels relieved as Astrid
hugs and Comforts her with a slew of
kind words the next morning the group is
informed that the boat will arrive the
following day to take them home the
guests are pleased to hear the news but
Aldo remains suspicious of the
inhabitants and decides to leave the
island on his own terms meanwhile the
rest of the group mingles and settles
seamlessly with the low vocals zoa
quickly gets attached to Nico while Ebon
shares a bond with a resident after the
duo plays a melancholic piece on a piano
that night Astrid and her husband Eric
throw a farewell party to celebrate
their guests impending departure while
the rest of the Islanders party all
night although plods the terrain and
discovers a cargo boat offloading
shipment at the shores Aldo takes this
as his chance to escape and rushes back
to the party to inform the others he
only manages to find Charlie and tells
him about his plan however an
intoxicated Charlie dismisses him
leaving Aldo with no choice but to
escape alone he swiftly returns to the
Island's Shores and swims to the boat
once aboard he hides amongst the cargo
and heaves a sigh of relief as he falls
asleep hours later Aldo is woken up by
the sound of the boat's engine failing
he quickly makes his way to the upper
deck and is startled to find one of the
Islanders staring at him on her
instruction Aldo falls to his knees and
fearfully stares at her without
hesitation she whips out a gadget and
uses it to Pierce all those skull thus
instantly killing him as she returns
with his corpse to the island right then
it is revealed that the island and its
inhabitants are all members of a cult
with Astrid being their leader she
instructs the locals to entice the
guests with their charm to have them
remain on the island forever the next
morning zoa freshens up as she prepares
for the boat's arrival excited to return
home she heads out in search of her
fellow guests however she quickly
discovers that Aldo is missing and
informs the others on hearing the news
Charlie recalls his encounter with Aldo
the previous night and tells zoa about
his Escape Plan the Revelation greatly
troubles zoa and makes her wary of the
locals as she increasingly anticipates
her departure from the island meanwhile
Astrid's plans to charm the guests into
staying were already in action due to
the Local's influence Africa and Ebon
decide to remain on the island and each
sign a contract binding them to the cult
back in the city Gabby worries about her
sister's disappearance and enlists the
help of their addict mother fortunately
the duo gets in touch with a police
officer who files a missing person
report on zoa however this doesn't
accomplish much as the police fail to
take proactive steps to find her
frustrated Gabby tries to convince her
mother to take a more drastic approach
but is merely ignored Gabby swiftly
reaches her breaking point and checks
his O's room for Clues a better
whereabouts there she finds her phone
and sees a text from a guy named Daniel
who happened to meet zoa on the Eden
trip Daniel recounts his encounter with
zoa and tells Gabby all about the invite
and the journey to the deserted island
Gabby is intrigued by this and
eventually schedules a meeting with
Daniel in hopes of finding her sister in
the following scene the Islanders
reconvene for their periodic therapy
session This Time Charlie is hand-picked
to share his story just like zoa he is
initially skeptical about joining the
session but is eventually coerced by
Astrid to open up Charlie talks at
length about his estranged relationship
with his family especially his mother
due to the loss of his baby sister it
turns out that she died in a drowning
accident when they were kids due to his
negligence hence his mother has hated
him ever since and hardly ever spoke to
him hearing this Astrid consoles Charlie
however before she can continue this
session zoa sees through her Antics and
has a fiery Outburst she calls Astrid
out for manipulating them into staying
and accuses the locals of lying about
the boat's arrival eventually Nico pulls
an angered zoa away from the group and
asks her to meet him later that night if
she wishes to discover the truth about
the island zoa is perplexed by his
explanation but agrees to see him later
that day at nightfall Nico leads her to
an underground cave and shows her a
corpse lying on a wooden structure upon
inspection zoa is horrified to discover
that the dead body on the pile is
actually Judith's the episode ends with
zoa erupting into a scream as tears
trickle down her cheeks to see what
happens next watch the second part in
series recapped